so that's
the the end the mortality the death of
human civilization that we've been
discussing in life
maybe prospering beyond any kind of
great filter
do you think about your own death does
it make you sad
that you may not witness some of the
you know you lead a research group on
working some of the biggest questions in
the universe actually
both on the physics and the ai side does
it make you sad that you may not be able
to see some of these
exciting things come to fruition that
we've been talking about
of course of course it sucks the fact
that i'm going to die
and i remember once when i was much
younger
my dad made this remark that life is
fundamentally tragic
and i'm like what are you talking about
that you know and then many years later
i i felt now i feel like i totally
understand what he means you know
we grow up very little kids and
everything is infinite
and it's so cool and then suddenly we
find out that actually you know
you've got a certain only this is that
you can get game over at some point
uh so of course it's it's it's um
it's something that's sad uh are you
afraid
no not in the sense that uh i think
anything terrible is gonna happen
after i die or anything like that no i i
think it's really going to be game over
but it's more that um
it makes me very acutely aware of i just
have what a wonderful gift this is that
i get to be alive right now
and and is a steady reminder to just
live life to the fullest and really
enjoy it because it is finite you know
and i think actually and we know we all
get the
regular reminders when someone near and
dear to us dies that
that um
you know one day it's going to be our
turn it adds this kind of focus
i wonder what it would feel like
actually to be an immortal being
if they might even enjoy some of the
wonderful things of life a little bit
less
just because there isn't that um
finiteness yeah do you think that could
be a feature not a bug
the fact that we beings are finite
maybe there's lessons for engineering in
artificial intelligence systems as well
that are conscious like do you think uh
it makes
is it possible that the reason the
pistachio ice cream is delicious
is the fact that you're going to die one
day and you will not have
all the pistachio ice cream that you
could eat
because of that fact well let me say two
things first of all i
it's actually quite profound what you're
saying i do think i appreciate the
pistachio ice cream a lot more
knowing that i will there's only finite
number of times i get to enjoy that
and i can only remember finding a number
of times in the past
and moreover my life is not so long that
it just starts to feel like things are
repeating themselves in general
it's so new and fresh um i also think
though that
beth is a little bit overrated and in
the sense that the
it comes from a sort of outdated view of
physics and what life actually is
because
if you ask okay what is it that's going
to die exactly what what
am i really when i say it i feel sad
about
the idea of myself dying am i really sad
that the skin cell here is going to die
of course not because it's going to die
next week anyway and i'll grow a new one
right and it's not any of my cells that
i'm
associating really with who i really am
and nor is it any of my atoms or quarks
or electrons
in fact basically all of my atoms get
replaced
on a regular basis right so what is it
that's really me
from a more modern physics perspective
it's the information
in processing amy that's where my my
memory that's my memories
that's my my values
my dreams my passion my love
it's that's what's really fundamentally
me
and frankly not all of that
will die when when my body dies like
richard feynman for
example his body died of cancer you know
but many of his ideas that he felt
were made him very him actually live on
i i this is my own little personal
tribute to richard feynman right i try
to keep a little bit of him alive in
myself
and i've even quoted him today right
yeah he almost
came alive for a brief moment in this
conversation yeah yeah
and and this honestly gives me some
solace you know
when i work as a teacher i feel
if i can actually share a bit about
myself
that my students feel worthy enough to
copy
and adopt some part of things that they
know or
or they believe or aspire to
now i live on also a little bit in them
right
and um i uh so
being a teacher is a little bit of what
i
uh that's something also that
contributes
to making me a little teeny bit less
mortal
right because i'm not at least not all
gonna die all at once
right and i find that a beautiful
tribute to people we generally respect
if we can if we can remember them and
carry in us
the things that we felt was the most
awesome about them right then they live
on
and i'm getting a bit emotionally over
but it's a very beautiful idea you bring
up there
i think we should stop this
old-fashioned materialism and just
equate
who we are with our quarks and electrons
there's no scientific basis for that
really and
it's also very uninspiring
now if you look a little bit towards the
future
right one thing which really sucks about
humans dying
is that even though some of their
teachings and memories and stories and
and ethics and so on will be copied by
those around them hopefully
a lot of it can't be copied and just
dies with them with a brain and that
really sucks
that that's the fundamental reason why
we find it so tragic
when someone goes from having all this
information there to the more just
gone ruined right with with uh
more post biological intelligence that's
going to shift
a lot right the only reason it's so hard
to make a backup of your brain
in its entirety is exactly because it
wasn't built for that right
if you have a future machine
intelligence
there's no reason for why it has to die
at all if it wants to up
if you want to copy it whatever is it
into some other quark blob
right you can copy not just something
but all of it right
and so so in that sense
you can get immortality because all the
information can be copied out of any
individual
entity and it's not just mortality that
will change if we get
more post biological life it's also
the with that i think very much the
whole
individual the whole individualism we
have now right the reason that we make
such a big difference between me and you
is exactly because we're a little bit
limited in how much we can copy like i
would just love to go like this
and copy your russian skills russian
speaking skills
yeah wouldn't it be awesome but i can't
i have to actually work for years if i
want to get better on it and
but if you have if we were robots
just copy and paste freely then that
loses completely
uh it washes away the sense of what
immortality is
and also individuality a little bit
right we would start feeling much more
maybe we would feel much more
collaborative with each other if we can
just
hey you know i'll give you my rush you
can give me your russian and i'll give
you whatever some
i can and suddenly you can speak swedish
maybe that's less a bad trade for you
but
but whatever else you want from my brain
right yeah and and um
there have been a lot of sci-fi stories
about hive minds and so on
where where people where experiences can
be more broadly shared
uh and uh i think one
we don't i don't pretend to know what it
would feel like
to be a super intelligent machine but
i'm quite confident that however it
feels about
mortality and individuality will be very
very different from how it is for us
well for us mortality and finiteness
seems to be
pretty important at this particular
moment and so
all good things must come to an end just
like this conversation
i saw that coming sorry this is
the world's worst translation i could
talk to you forever it's such a huge
honor that you spend time with me
uh honor is mine thank you so much for
getting me essentially to start this
podcast by doing the first conversation
making me realize
uh falling in love with conversation in
itself
and thank you so much for inspiring so
many people in the world with your books
with your research with your talking and
with the
other the like this this ripple effect
of friends including
elon and everybody else that you inspire
so
thank you so much for talking today
thank you i feel like we're
so fortunate that this you're doing this
podcast and getting so many
interesting voices out there into the
ether
and not just the five second sound bites
but so many of the interviews of what
you do
you really let people go in into depth
in a way which we surely need in this
day and age and that i got to be number
one i feel super honored
yeah you start thank you so much max
you